bom dia a todos é um prazer imenso estar
aqui hoje de de falar de uma coisa que
eu amo de que eu gosto é a minha paixão
que é o design e aí completando
completando com o pensamento não é bom
eu tenho 25 anos de experiência na área
de design
cresci dentro de uma indústria de
eletrodomésticos cheguei a gerência de
design da américa latina de algumas
marcas
é também nesse onu é pra turma de design
já há 15 anos o professor e coordenador
de pós-graduação na e professor de
graduação e hoje eu faço trabalhos além
de consultoria com empresas na parte
design estratégico eu também trabalho
com cidades e economia criativa e no
desenvolvimento do arranjo produtivo
local
tá e isso realmente o que me deixa mais
emocionado porque aí eu tô inserindo
design na vida das pessoas e não mais em
produzir um produto para ganhar um
prêmio e assim por diante
bom pra falar agora um pouco do que é
design thinking a gente tem que olhar um
pouquinho no passado
vamos ver o que vem acontecendo é o que
aconteceu nos últimos 30 anos aqui no
brasil para que a gente entenda qual é o
próximo passo a gente precisa entender o
passado e ver o que ela vem mudando com
de comportamento e fim de de série de
uma série de coisas do década de 80 o
design como ele é inserido dentro da
indústria ele era o bracinho da
engenharia
tá é essen do bracinho da engenharia e
pensava em forma e função ou seja ele
dava forma por uma função o que vendia
em na década de 80 vende um produto
funcional é em 90 gente teve enxurrada
de programas da qualidade dentro da
empresa e o designer fazendo parte desse
processo porém um pouco amargo porque
amargo porque é um processo burocrático
e de hierarquia e o principal inimigo da
criatividade talvez os principais são a
hierarquia e à burocracia
aliás na linguagem do design burocracia
nasceu para ser burlada
então a gente faz um pouco disso mas em
meados dessa década apareceu à internet
as grandes indústrias entraram aqui no
brasil
com isso o grande número de concorrentes
e quando a gente passa a ter mais
concorrentes veio o primeiro marco do
design que era diferenciação estética no
seu ponto de venda
certo ea partir desse momento nessa
revolução estética o design passa a ser
importante
quando cheguei em 2000 designer deixa de
ser um brasil da engenharia e vai ser um
brasil do marketing
tá e sem do bracinho do mar que ele se
aproxima perto dos consumidores ele se
aproxima perto das pessoas
ainda faltando uma visão mais humana mas
ele se aproxima disso e importa algumas
ferramentas que ele já havia prendido
engenharia e conecta com que ele começa
a aprender em marketing e depois disso
do ano 2000 meados de 2004 2005 aparece
o design thinking aqui no brasil
tá quando ele aparece no brasil a
profissão começa a se reinventar o
designer hoje não é o mesmo da década de
80 e de 90 ele pensa diferente ea gente
teve o suporte óbvio de steve jobs da
procter gamble e uma série de coisas que
mostraram design como estratégia e de
quanto ele agregará valor dos seus
produtos e serviços
ok bom pensando nessa passagem vamos
pegar só para entender um pouco o que a
gente vendia no passado se a gente for
pegar um óleo de motor o que ele vendia
o atributo racional era o lugar fica
melhor década de 80 depois benefícios
funcionais ele começou a vender que era
o carro quebra - padrão de qualidade
depois benefícios emocionais
tranquilidade para viajar quando já
começa a entrar no mundo do design by
brand e depois valores emocionais que
hoje todo mundo falar qual o seu valor
o que você vende porque você vende certo
então essa evolução de sair de produtos
chegarem serviços do tangível para o
intangível
o que acontece hoje a gente vende a tal
da experiência nem todo mundo é preciso
promover uma nova experiência mas que a
experiência é essa experiência é uma
fórmula 1
ativa - percepção a expectativa é que
você tem de consumir alguma coisa versus
a percepção de quando você consome que
te dá uma experiência satisfatória ou
insatisfatória né ea partir desse
momento onde a gente começa a falar um
pouco mais sobre design thinking
é só olhar aqui na evolução do celular
não é o que a gente vende antes e o que
a gente vem de hoje
o que tem na nossa mão hoje uma série de
serviços e de experiência em um único
produto quais serviços gps e mail
internet cronômetro enfim agenda uma
série de coisas e único produto
mas aí vem a pergunta e agora né
o que vai acontecer 2020 e 2025 2030
parece longe mas chega né a pergunta é
qual o valor das coisas
o que vamos consumir como vamos consumir
porque vamos consumir de quem vamos
consumir como vamos usar e descartar
certo então são essas perguntas
e por que eu coloque essas perguntas
porque no passado o design respondia
hoje ele aprendeu perguntar então essa é
a nossa função
bom aí um vídeo só para você entender o
valor das coisas
é má
é mau
a afirmar que é mau por exemplo é que se
sai melhor piraju
então tá aí né o total do valor das
coisas depende do momento e situação e é
isso que o design entende momento e
situação bom encontrando perguntando
sobre o que está a acontecer daquelas
perguntas a que mencionei qual a visão
de futuro né qual é a visão de futuro de
vocês com a visão de futuro da empresa e
dos negócios sendo que a gente vive uma
uma sociedade bombardeada por marcas a
gente da hora que acorda hora que a
gente dorme é uma série de marcas que
vão bombardeando a nossa cabeça
mais de 3500 mensagens por dia como eu
faço uma chegar no meu coração como eu
faço uma ser percebida
tá depois a gente vive um momento de
incerteza e ambiguidade
tá eu converso com os empresários a
maioria não está nem em busca do
conhecimento estão em busca da certeza
há um medo muito grande por parte do
empresariado no desenvolvimento de
qualquer que seja o seu produto ou
serviço e mais do que isso além de a
gente ficar empurrando um monte de coisa
na prateleira de querer vender mais para
promover esse consumo
a gente tem a escassez quando eu falei
do celular o que ele promove um número
infinito de informações com isso começa
a faltar tempo quando a habilidade de
hoje do ser humano
gerir o seu próprio tempo qual é a
escassez à privacidade por exemplo e
quando a gente fala de escassez na linha
do tempo a gente entende que tudo que
vai faltando vai ficando caro valioso tá
então quando eu fiz essa pergunta para
os adultos
qual era a visão do futuro eles me
responder essas imagens mobilidade lixo
a seca é a segurança a educação uma
série de coisas
essa é a visão de futuro de nós adultos
nada mais é do que o mundo negro cinza
essa é a visão da maioria das pessoas é
bom e agora porque design antes de falar
do team porque o design nós designers
estamos acostumados com incertezas e com
big daddies nós designers trazemos um
cenário futuro e é por isso que hoje o
design talvez uma das ferramentas
principais ferramentas da inovação
mas o que é design fácil procurando
google não é
olha aqui ó eu nem sei falar que o
número é esse mas tende ao infinito
ok digita a palavra de deus e digita
design ver o que vocês estão procurando
o primeiro estão procurando mais dizendo
que deus tá deus é um número muito menor
do que isso e aí a informação processar
essa informação não é pode aparecer
diversas coisas sobre design desde que
tenha fundamento não discordo mas a
gente tem que tomar muito cuidado com as
informações do que é design na minha
opinião que é design é quando você muda
uma situação um produto ou um serviço
existentes para que seja escolhido o
preferido é por isso que uma empresa
procura um designer para que o seu
serviço seu produto seja o preferido
escolhido
e é aqui que o designer trabalha no
escolhido preferido
quais são as ferramentas que vão levar
ao ponto de venda ou para a comunicação
para que ele seja escolhido o preferido
mas com relevância com valor percebido
para que o cara perceba ou aquilo que
você está vendendo a sua verdade
e aí entra o design thinking o design
thinking assim existem algumas perguntas
e vocês vão entender se vocês pensam
design não pensou design primeira delas
vocês são eficientes são inovadores essa
pergunta eu falo para as empresas o que
é eficiente estudam um cenário atual e
explora um cenário atual nicho de
mercado concorrente material tecnologia
as empresas tendem a ser eficientes
inovação é um cenário que não existe
com a diferença pensamento analítico
versus pensamento intuitivo
tá depois a sua empresa olha para o
consumidor o usuário a mesma pessoa
depende da percepção das coisas
o designer olha para o usuário o
designer vivencia o dia a dia do usuário
vocês analisam o problema a necessidade
e se esse daqui
é talvez seja uma pergunta muito
importante
a empresa entrega no seu briefing uma
série de problemas com a solução é o
designer fica amarrado aqueles problemas
que a indústria percebeu
vou dar um exemplo porque o orkut morreu
ele morreu porque matou a principal
necessidade das pessoas vigiar a vida
dos outros sem ser percebido
certo problemas e necessidades o
instagram o que ele resolveu os dois
necessidade um canal de você se conectar
a uma rede de relacionamentos problemas
eu não conseguia mostrar uma foto
adequada o instagram deu o instagram de
uma série de filtros onde o connectu com
todo mundo e mostra uma foto bem
detalhada
eu crio para as pessoas ou com as
pessoas criar para as pessoas
vivenciarem uma bolha criar com as
pessoas
chamar as pessoas para o desenvolvimento
de alguma coisa chamar o usuário
chamaram uma equipe multidisciplinar
mas uma coisa no design
se você erra fala não esconde que a
empresa tinha muito difícil esconder o
que tinha errado no design a
materialização é pra descobrir o erro é
pra mostrar o erro e se eu entrego valor
tangível ou intangível sendo que o valor
intangível das coisas hoje refere-se a
70% do valor de um produto ou um serviço
e por último a refletir o designer
reflete e é isso o que é ser de pensar
designer ser inovador olhar para o
usuário analisar necessidades de seus
conjuntos de problemas errar e errar
mais rápido quem sai na frente hoje quem
descobre o erro primeiro e entrega do
valor intangível
o design thinking toda empresa tem um
departamento que pensa e toda empresa
tem um departamento que faz oque pensar
sem fazer é um sonho fazer sem pensar um
pesadelo onde entra o design no coração
ele conecta essas áreas
ele sente-se eu quero vender alguma
coisa é preciso sentir aquilo que estou
fazendo
o designer significa isso não é pensar
design
esse emaranhado de coisas para que a
gente chegue a uma solução ou um
processo de divergência e convergência
ok
baseado em três perguntas o que come
porque certo então é o que eu quero
descobrir e definir suas necessidades
como eu resolvo definir e desenvolver o
conjunto de problemas que envolve essa
necessidade e o porquê eu entrego alguma
coisa essas três perguntas são super
importantes porque o que vocês estão
fazendo aqui todo mundo sabe
estou participando de um evento ted como
vocês estão fazendo isso já começa a
mudar agora o porquê vocês estão aqui
que é o importante porque a busca pela
qual eu quero apresentar é uma causa
tá e é nisso que a empresa precisa
comunicar mas para comunicar porque ela
precisa passar pelas outras perguntas
briefing qual o resultado de de briefing
né
o briefing aquele conjunto de problemas
que o carro entregue uma solução e antes
a gente trabalhava da kipata o que faz o
designer hoje vai lá atrás para ter uma
redefinição de si briefing
isso significa um briefing o que é isso
uma favela é uma favela
só que essa favela está de cabeça para
baixo qual o risco do briefing confundir
o familiar com conhecido bom esse é o
mapa do design thinking
estou de olho no relógio aqui porque é o
meu grande desafio
o design tem quem é baseado em três
coisas empate arte de conhecer as
pessoas colaboração a arte de criar
coletivamente prototipação a arte de
aprender com o erro rapidamente esse é o
processo de design thinking onde a gente
vai da descoberta a evolução bom falando
um pouco do design thinking pra mim é
esse gráfico esse gráfico que mais se
apresenta o pensamento do design
thinking que é você se conectar o
coração das pessoas porque isso porque
eu posso falar sobre um serviço que eu
tenho um produto mas as pessoas podem
esquecer
eu posso mostrar
o que eu faço o que eu entrego mas as
pessoas também podem esquecer
agora quando eu faço essas pessoas
sentirem o que eu quero de verdade ela
não esquece
antes de ir pro último vídeo é quando eu
perguntei para uma série de adultos qual
é o futuro uma visão de futuro e ele
respondeu o futuro cinza quando eu
perguntei para as crianças ela responder
um futuro colorido
a pergunta é o futuro já é o futuro não
é esse o futuro não é porque eu tenho
que pensar no cinza porque eu não posso
contribuir com o pensamento das crianças
eu vou mostrar agora um vídeo que
retrata o que eu quero falar da
experiência o que uma indústria de
eletrodomésticos fez pra conquistar o
coração das pessoas
antes tudo bem posso abrir aqui
a superprodução da fifa
é bom correr uma série de natal então
nessa mesma linha de natal do senhor
sair
ganhou
como é trabalhar no natal a gente sente
falta sente saudade né
aquela vontade de estar perto né mas
sabe que as pessoas que estão
necessitando a nossa ajuda é preciso
muito mais do que nossas esposas nossos
filhos que estão em segurança em casa a
gente tem que por isso
a primeira vez que eu fique longe dentro
o coração mesmo muito feliz foi uma
surpresa
eu queria propor um brinde pra todos
vocês um feliz natal
o
bom gente era isso que eu queria mostrar
muito obrigado pela oportunidade